und
Beugen Leute
Heute ist richtig gutes Wetter, aber ich bin meine eineinhalb Stunden schon gelaufen. Ich habe jetzt den ganzen Tag nichts anderes mehr vor
Oh, ich sehe gerade, ich habe den Chat gar nicht richtig auf. Seck
Jetzt tatsächlich mal zur Abwechslung. Es gibt nämlich einen neuen Half-Life 1 Mod und nachdem ich einmal jährlich Half-Life 1, also mindestens einmal jährlich Half-Life 1 durchspiele, freue ich mich schon die ganze Zeit darauf, mal wieder das Original zu spielen. Allerdings mit Mod-Gear, zwar wir spielen das heute mit
M-Mod
Gibt es auf Steam, kostet nix
Nicht Mod, M-Mod, Steam
Kam es vor ein paar Wochen raus
Und
Also, ich habe gestern schon mal so eine halbe Stunde oder so reingeguckt, weil ich wissen wollte, was mich so ungefähr erwartet, ja
Weil bei Half-Life Mods gibt es ja alles. Ich glaube, Half-Life dürfte somit das meist gemoddete Game
aller Zeiten sein und weiß ich nicht, ob das, also auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall vorne mit dabei, ja
Dass die Musik nicht zu laut ist
Minecraft vielleicht, wobei ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich immer noch Half-Life, weil einfach Half-Life irgendwie 15 Jahre Vorsprung hatte vor Minecraft
Wobei Minecraft ist auch alt, immer 10 Jahre Vorsprung hatte vor Minecraft, ja zumindest
Also, soweit ich das, soweit ich das gelesen habe, haben die einige Sachen überarbeitet, also es ist die originale Half-Life 1 Kampagne, allerdings
Also, wie gesagt, so
Ich habe es gestern schon mal eine halbe Stunde angeguckt, also so, es hat sich, es hat sich schon einiges geändert, also die haben mehr Gegner
Die haben mehr Waffen
Die haben angepasste Waffen, die haben teilweise etwas angepasste Level, allerdings sagen sie selbst, die wollen quasi so den, so den Geist des Games
Erhalten, also wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht super, total abgedreht angepasste Level, aber ein bisschen angepasst sind sie wohl, also gestern habe ich zum Beispiel
gesehen, dass jetzt an manchen Stellen, wo halt im originalen Half-Life nix war, jetzt Gegner spawnen und sowas
Mal gucken, ne hab ich nicht, hab keine VR-Brille, huch, warum ist das Sound aus, Moment
10, 10, Aua, warum war das
Wenn, wenn ich ein bisschen erzähle, ja
Spiele ich das heute komplett durch, da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher, ich würde wahrscheinlich, also ich würde prinzipiell gerne
Also Half-Life, Half-Life 1 ist ein relativ langes Game, wenn man es zum ersten Mal spielt, wenn man das ein paar Mal gespielt hat
kann man durchaus, denke ich mal, so in
Vier Stunden, dreieinhalb, vier Stunden durch sein
Ich weiß gar nicht, warte mal, Speedrun, Half-Life 1, was ist denn der aktuelle Weltrekord? Nicht, dass es jetzt zwei Stunden ist, in denen ich hier irgendwie Mist erzähle
Okay, sechs
26 Minuten
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt, das müssen wir uns nachher angucken
Das gucken wir nicht jetzt an, das gucken wir nachher an, bin ich mal gespannt, Alter, 26 Minuten, okay, also
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als ich Half-Life zum ersten Mal gespielt hab
Guck, es gibt neue Waffen und solche Geschichten, ich glaub, ich glaub, das Ding haben sie irgendwie gemoddet aus Opposing Force importiert und sowas
Also zumindest, die Musik ist zu laut, was ist da los, warum?
Ja, okay, also sie haben, wie gesagt, sie haben wohl einiges gemoddet, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, also als ich Half-Life 1 zum ersten Mal
gespielt hab, also irgendwann 1997, 98 oder sowas rum
Da habe ich bestimmt, keine Ahnung, eine Woche oder so gespielt
mit Stunden, mit ein paar Stunden am Tag, bis ich das erste Mal durch war
Ich war damals auch mega schlecht, was solche Games anging und man hatte ja sowas doch in der Richtung noch gar nicht gespielt
Und ich glaube, es gibt kein Game, was ich öfters durchgespielt habe als Half-Life 1, allerdings
ist das Ganze auch schon ein bisschen her, wo ich zum letzten Mal das Original gespielt habe und wobei, mal gucken, wie viel Original
davon, davon übrig, nein, nein, ich will keinen, danke für die Zeit, aber ich will keinen Speedrun machen
Mal gucken, wie viel vom Original noch übrig ist, aber sie sagen, sie haben sich stark am Original orientiert und auf die Frage hin, ob das, wie
wie stark sich das zu Black Mesa unterscheidet, naja, der größte Unterschied ist, also der
obvious Unterschied ist, das ist Half-Life 1 gemoddet und Black Mesa ist
Half-Life 1 quasi etwas moderner nachgebaut in der Source-Engine, also das ist schon immer noch Gold-Source-Half-Life-1-Engine
bloß halt gemoddet, guck, man kann jetzt, man hat zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie einen Schalldämpfer für die Pistole und es gibt wohl auch einen extra
extra Feuermodus, kann man das Feuermodus nennen, für, für die, für das Brecheisen und sowas, ja, gibt neue Partikeleffekte, neue
Monstertypen
oder neue Gegner, sind ja nicht unbedingt Monster, neue Gegnertypen
Neue Waffen-Attachments, wie diesen komischen Laser-Pointe an der Shotgun, an dem Revolver und
also sie haben wohl einiges gemacht, also sie schreiben selbst, lass mal, ah, genau, hier steht's noch, hier ist noch die Übersicht, was die, was die gemacht haben
Huge thanks für dich, Batocera-Video
Ja, das ist mega nice, ne, ich hab hier auch meine Emulator-Kiste stehen
Da kann man wenigstens mal eine alte, alte Kiste auch neu, neu beleben
Also ich hoffe, dass ich's heute durchgespielt kriege, wenn nicht, müssen wir die Tage weitermachen, ich weiß nicht, wie, also
Ich glaube, man kann auch als Noob Half-Life durchaus so in vier Stunden durchspielen
Ich hab das Original ewig nicht gespielt, also das letzte Mal, als ich durchgespielt hab
war tatsächlich, also Black Mesa hab ich auch schon ein paar mal durchgespielt, allerdings das
Original Half-Life 1
Das hab ich, das hab ich sehr lange nicht mehr gespielt
Also von Anfang bis Ende, das wirklich, wirklich lange, zehn Jahre vielleicht
Wobei, nee, kann nicht, kann nicht sein
Also, ich, ich spiel, ich spiel eigentlich mindestens einmal im Jahr irgendwas Half-Life mäßiges
Aber das, aber die Original-Kampagne in der Original-Engine hab ich schon wirklich eine ganze Weile nicht mehr gespielt
Naja, zumindest, sie, sie schreiben mir selbst, was sie gemacht haben, also es gibt
Ach ja, stimmt, die haben die Waffen wohl auch angepasst, dass die Waffen jetzt zum größten Teil Projektile schießen und, schießen und nicht mehr Hitscan sind
Was wahrscheinlich dem Gameplay ganz gut tut, weil es, es war ja, also Half-Life 1 Gameplay war ja eh ein bisschen
Aus heutigen Maßstäben zumindest, ein bisschen sehr
Click, Click and Shoot halt, ne, du, was du mit dem Fahnenkreuz über den Gegner hast geschossen hast, hat getroffen, die Gegner auch, dementsprechend
Ach, Movement ist jetzt auch dazu wirklich wichtig
Also, sie haben Gunplay überarbeitet
Bullet Spreads, Rückstoß, hier Optional Non-Hitscan Bullets, wir müssen gleich mal in die Options gehen
Und mal gucken, was man da alles einschalten kann
Sie haben die Grafik verbessert, ach ja, und, und Gordon Freeman hat jetzt Beine, hab ich schon gesehen, im Vorschau-Video
Man hat jetzt Beine, also, das gab es ja damals noch nicht, ich bin mir gar nicht mal ehrlich gesagt sicher, hatte man in Half-Life 2 überhaupt schon Beine, glaub nicht, weiß ich gar nicht
Sie haben die AI ein bisschen verbessert und, und ganz, oh, ganz, ganz wichtig
Alle Charaktere blinken jetzt mit den Augen, nicht blinken, blinzeln jetzt mit den Augen
Neue Waffen, neue Waffen-Animationen
Chapter Selection, wir brauchen die, die, die erste, die Fahrt mit der, mit der Bahn nicht zu machen
Der Waffen-Modell überarbeitet neue Animationen, neue, neue Waffen, Spezial-Waffen-Funktionen, Silencer-Addons, also Attachments, Fire-Modi, Bugs-Gefixts, bessere Explosionen, Muzzle-Flashes, alles mögliche
Also, sie haben das Original genommen und so in ihrer Vision verbessert, mal gucken
Also, das erste was mir gestern, ich hab gestern das erste, bin ich kurz durchgeflitzt durch, durch das, durch das, das, die ersten 1, 2 Chapter
Das geht ja auch sehr zackig
Äh, es sieht grafisch besser aus als das originale Half-Life, glaub das kann man sagen
Aber es, es ist halt jetzt auch keine Wunder zu erwarten, ich mein, es ist immerhin noch das originale Half-Life auf der, auf der original Gold-Source-Engine
Na gut, dann gucken wir uns das mal an, ich mach mal die Musik aus
Gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an, wir müssen mal schauen
Ob, lass mal kurz, hier, Game Screen Capture, wir müssen mal kurz gucken, ob die Lautstärke okay ist
Und ich muss den
Äh, und ich muss den Fenstermodus ausschalten, weil mit Fenstermodus suckt
Äh, geht das jetzt?
Ja, doch, ich seh's in der Vorschau, passt alles
So, wir müssen jetzt gleich mal die Lautstärke checken
Aber vorher gucken wir uns mal die Optionen an, was man alles so einstellen kann
Lautst, Lautstärke müsste, glaub ich, halbwegs passen
Lass mal gucken, also die Half-Life Menü-Sounds waren nie sonderlich gut
Also, was kann man einstellen? Okay
Keyboard, alles, alles Standard
Ich mein, Half-Life ist ja das Spiel, was diese ganze WASD-Geschichte mit definiert hat
Ähm
Use Items weiterhin auf E
Swim Up, Swim Down, hat eh niemand verwendet
Control
C
Damit ich, okay, die Musik ist zu laut
Musik ist ein bisschen laut, ja, wartet mal
Ich mach mal, ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen leiser
Wir müssen so gucken, wie's in-Game ist, der Menü-Sound, der sagt ja noch gar nix aus
Ja, ich glaub, so ist besser
Ja, WASD-Steuerung gab's schon früher, aber ich
Also, das erste Spiel, an das ich mich erinnern kann
Mit WASD-Steuerung, wo ich so bewusst WASD gespielt habe bei Half-Life
So, Raw Mouse Input, blablabla, achso, was mich noch interessieren würde, ist
Wie macht man Custom, Custom Weapon Attachments, seht ihr hier irgendwas?
Vielleicht Use mit der Waffe, ohne dass man vor nem Switch steht?
Es müsste ja sowas wie Weapon Attachments oder sowas geben
Hat der da jetzt irgendwas gesehen?
Ach hier, Primary Attack, Secondary Attack, Weapon Function ist es wahrscheinlich
Okay, mittlere Maustaste, mittlere Maustaste ist es anscheinend
Okay, Maus ruhig, Audio lassen wir alles, wie's ist, Video lassen wir auch alles, wie's ist
Das lassen wir auch alles so...
Quatsch, brauchen wir nicht
Okay, na Moment, Game-Difficulty stellen wir erstmal auf Hard, ich mein, wir sind ja keine Kack-Noobs
Kamera lassen wir, ich lass einfach alles an
Texturen, Waffen, Bullets, gut, Fade Corps, das lassen wir aus, die dürfen ruhig da bleiben
Ach ja, und es gibt neue, und es gibt neue Splatter-Effekte anscheinend
Lasst uns mal kurz...
Warte mal, ich geh mal irgendwo rein und wir müssen mal kurz die Lautstärke testen
Ich glaub, es ist ein bisschen laut noch, oder?
Ich glaub, es ist immer noch ein bisschen...
Ich glaub, so ist es gut
Ich glaub, so ist es ganz gut
Okay, nice
Disconnect?
Ja, passt, richtiger Boomer-Shooter, das ist eines DER Boomer-Shooter schlechthin
Ach guck mal, jetzt gibt's auch im Menü kein Sound mehr
Okay, eins trinken, ja, danke
Ah, yes!
Okay, ihr könnt's euch aussuchen, Chat
Fangen wir mit Intro-Video an, äh, nicht Intro-Video
Intro-Bahnfahrt an oder überspringen wir die Intro-Bahnfahrt?
Ach komm, die dauert 5 Minuten, das können wir uns geben, das gehört irgendwie dazu
Äh, ich glaub, Sound passt so
Guck mal, Barney am Start
Ähm, vorher müssen wir noch eine andere Sache...
Guck mal!
Ich wusste...
Den Bug gab's früher schon, manchmal zumindest
Da gab's zwar nicht dieses Modding-Menü
Aber der hat teilweise den Schwierigkeitsgrad nicht richtig mit übernommen
Den Rest hat er aber, ne?
Gut, auf geht's
Oh, wir haben mit dem...
Ich, ich hab die Bahnansage kaputt gemacht mit dem Pausedrücken
Ich hab's, ich hab's, okay
Ich hab's zerstört
Okay, okay, okay
Hat er jetzt, hat er jetzt die Schwierigkeit...
Alter, was ist das?
Warum ist der Schwierigkeitsgrad immer wieder falsch?
Okay, Prager, hoffentlich geht die Bahnansage nicht wieder kaputt
Fuck, die ist wieder kaputt
Kann man, kann man vielleicht safen und laden, dass die wieder geht?
Na gut, der Schwierigkeitsgrad, der Schwierigkeitsgrad am Anfang ist ja auch egal
Ach, Quatsch
Ist das die selbe Story wie in Half-Life 2?
Nein, das ist die selbe Story wie in Half-Life 1
Hatte Barney nicht ne Weste früher an?
Mr. Amec, danke für den Zap
Was mich früher auch immer wahnsinnig gemacht hat in Half-Life ist
Vielleicht, vielleicht erkennt ihr's
Wenn ich springe, ich drücke nicht nach vorne, guckt mal
Half-Life-Physics
Wenn man springt, fliegt man nach hinten in der Bahn
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr schon mal in ne echte Bahn gesprungen seid
Aber es ist wie in echt, ne, dann fliegt man auch immer gegen die Wand
Dachte, das mit dem Zug ist in Half-Life 2
Ja, in Half-Life 2 ist das auch mit dem Zug
Und weißt du, warum das in Half-Life 2 in nem Zug anfängt?
Weil Half-Life 1 auch in nem Zug anfange, angefangen hat
Vielleicht hast du dich auch gewundert, warum das das Ende von
Was, das Ende von Episode 2?
Ne, das Ende von Half-Life Alyx ist es, oder?
Das ist doch auch im Zug
Und in Half-Life 3 wird's garantiert auch wieder Züge geben
Du liebst Züge?
Oh ja, da gefällt dir das erste Kapitel in Half-Life auf jeden Fall
Übrigens, es kann sein, dass wir uns demnächst tatsächlich nochmal ne Runde Half-Life 1 geben müssen
Weil ich will ein bisschen Reshading ausprobieren
Und es gibt ein Raytracing-Mod
Leider funktioniert der Raytracing-Mod nicht mit M-Mod
Guckt euch mal diese High-Res-Textures an
Ich hab damals recht viel rumgebastelt in dem Half-Life 1 Level-Editor
Das nannte sich damals noch WorldCraft oder WorldEdit? Bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
Und da hab ich auch versucht solche
Ich wusste genau, dass das jetzt kommt
Ist echt der Wahnsinn, wie lange man das nach 20 Jahren noch weiß, ey
Da hab ich auch versucht solche Tür-Animationen zu machen, weil ich das so nice fand, wie hier die Türen aufgehen im Tunnel
Ja, bei mir sieht das Geländer draußen genauso aus
Dings kann einpacken bei den Textures hier
Unrecord
Oh, das
Leute, das hat mich jetzt hart gehittet gerade
Wisst ihr, was da stand?
Gordon Freeman, age 27
Als ich das das erste Mal gelesen hab, hab ich mir gedacht, was ein alter Sack
Und heute bin ich 38
Ist echt so
Ich hab damals gedacht, oh, der ist aber alt
Boah, krass
Das hat mich jetzt echt getroffen
Ich muss mal kurz noch die Maus etwas entwirren hier, meine Maus für den Vorschau-Rechner
Alter, wo geht denn die Maus lang?
Hier, unterm Rechner lang?
Okay, nice
Sector C, Testlabs
Erstmal kurz, ich muss mal kurz die Maus testen
Ja, geht
Hast du schon graue Haare? Ja
Gordon Freeman hat keine grauen Haare
Wusste sie eigentlich, dass Gordon Freeman ursprünglich eine Brille aufhaben sollte?
Oder sogar auf dem Original-Coverart eine Brille aufhatte?
Bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das noch Canon ist
Ah, da sind wir
Sector C
Wir sind wieder da
High-Res-Exit-Schild
So, jetzt muss ich noch warten, bis die Wache kommt
Sind auch noch mit Brille im Kopf?
Ich bilde mir ein...
Okay, dann vielleicht bring ich es auch durcheinander
Endproductive Day
Running late
Also es gab Zeiten, da hab ich das Spiel so oft gespielt
Und ich hab, wie gesagt, das ist glaube ich das für mich mit Abstand meist durchgespielte
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz was machen
Meist gespielte Gameplay, vielleicht Secret of Mana noch ein Ticken mehr
Ich konnte euch die Bandansage von der...
Von der Train wollte ich gerade sagen hier
Von dieser Gondel konnte ich fast im Schlaf auswendig
Aflav 2 hat Brille, okay
Okay, ich merk schon den ersten Unterschied
Das...
Wobbeln der Kamera
Das war im Original nicht so
Oh, die Sounds
Also ich hab ja
Oder besser gesagt, wir haben ja auch im Stream
Black Mesa schon mal gespielt von Anfang bis Ende
Und die haben das sehr gut nachgebaut
Aber trotzdem, man muss sagen, die Original Sounds
Und die Original Graphics und so
Auch wenn es besser aussieht als das Original
Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was sie gemacht haben
Ob sie die Texturen geupdatet haben
Oder ob sie irgendwie auch noch die...
Ne, die Levels, die sehen genauso aus wie...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was sie gemacht haben
Die...
Die Gesichter von den Wachen sehen auch definitiv anders aus als im Original
Ach übrigens, mal gucken, ob es das Wichtigste noch geht
Wenn ich den Knopf hier drücke
Okay, das geht immer noch
Geht aber nur einmal
Okay, auf geht's
Müssen wir uns einen Anzug holen
Wenn ich das auch richtig im Kopf hab
Hier lang, ne?
Jo, hier lang, rechts rum
Zack, hier ist die Küche mit der Mikrowelle, die man kaputt machen kann
Kaputt
So, jetzt können wir noch den Typ auf dem Klo stören schnell
Der war...
Ne
Hier, hier ist der Typ mit dem Klo, genau
Hat er nicht was gesagt früher?
Entticken lauter können wir es glaube ich machen
Nee, der sagt nicht mehr
Du hast einfach bis auf 5 oder so alle Zuschauer von Half-Life auf ganz Twitch
Ja gut
Wer streamt auch sonst noch Half-Life
So, jetzt können wir es mal auf schwer umstellen
Save
Okay, machen wir mal ein bisschen hinne
Sonst wird das heute nix mit den 4 Stunden
Wir brauchen unseren Anzug
So eines der ikonischsten Sachen glaube ich in ganz Half-Life
Zendrix, dankeschön für die Giftzaps
5 Stück
Und blöd für alle die gedodged haben
Dodged, easy dodge
Vegas, danke für den Zap
Hell yeah, Kekona
Okay, an den Leveln haben sie nicht viel gemacht
Aber die Steuerung ist auf jeden Fall weicher
Aha
Geht immer noch
Kann entweder die Leiter klettern oder
Ihr müsst mal drauf achten
Was die in Black Mesa teilweise für total unsinnige
Fahrstühle haben
Das wird auch noch im Lauf des Games auffallen, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat
Die sind teilweise sehr
Ragwürdig platziert
Und auch von der Funktion her auch ziemlich merkwürdig
Hello
Musste man damals schon
Weiß ich nicht, ich konnte nie Bunnyhoppen in dem Game
So
Dann gehen wir mal in die Testchamber
Und lassen uns erzählen, dass wir ein highly trained professional sind
Auf
Move dich
Aufmachen
Leon, 5 Gifts und Zaps, dankeschön Leute
Heute geht es ja richtig zur Sache
Hogu
Wer ist wieder gedodged?
Testchamber
Ach der macht auf
Es gibt irgendeine Speedrun-Strategie
Da muss man die NPCs so schubsen, dass es schneller geht
Aber
Keine Ahnung
Übrigens, die zwei Dudes hier
Die zwei Dudes, das sind
Oder der Dude
Ne, keine Ahnung
Ich glaube in Half-Life sind die einfach random meist, die Wissenschaftler
Wobei er hier nicht
Also laut offizieller Half-Life Story
Ist der Wissenschaftler hier
Der Typ aus Half-Life 2
Und der hier, der nicht so aussieht
Der andere ist eigentlich auch der aus Half-Life 2
Also die zwei Dudes sind das aus Half-Life 2
Auch wenn die halt überhaupt nicht so aussehen
Außer dass er schwarz ist
Aber ansonsten sehen die überhaupt nicht so aus
Das ist auch so typisch
Guck mal
Niemand würde einen Fahrstuhl an dieser Stelle so dahin bauen
Also die Black Mesa Architekten waren schon echt bisschen pp-ger
Highly trained professional sind wir
Gordon don't need to hear all of this
He is a highly trained professional
Gordon doesn't need to hear all of this
We've assured the administrator that nothing will go wrong
Ah yes, you're right
Gordon doesn't need to hear all of this
Well, go ahead
Let's let him in now
Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass die Texturen damals ganz so verwaschen gewesen sind
Ich glaube das liegt daran
Weil der Mod die ungefilterten Texturen standardmäßig hat
Was auch nicht verkehrt ist
Weil ansonsten sehen die Texturen einfach nur verwaschen aus
Ne, du konntest die Texturen auf jeden Fall filtern lassen
Und dann sahen die nicht so pixelig aus
Aber halt verwaschen
Was im Endeffekt auch nicht unbedingt besser ist
Egal, wir müssen jetzt uns bisschen sputen, weil wir das ja heute durchkriegen wollen
Ne, Moment, das war doch gar nicht so, oder?
Everything's be in order
Stellzeug, genau
Das sollten wir jedes Meeting bringen
Ich brauch das nicht hören, ich bin ein highly trained professional
Und meistens stimmt das ja
Meistens wäre die Antwort
Ich mein, die klingt halt super abgehoben und fies
Aber oftmals wäre die Antwort sogar richtig
Guck mal, ich hab Beine, seht ihr das?
Legit Beine
Echt, echt, okay
Das Klettern ist natürlich klar, aber
Und kann ich crouchen?
Moment, kann ich crouchen und das geht auch?
Moment
Wartet mal
Guck mal, man kann sogar crouchen
Und es versucht so ein bisschen zu crouchen
Now
Ist das das gleiche wie Black Mesa?
Ne, Black Mesa ist ein Nachbau hiervon
Mit leicht anderen Levels
Wobei ich nicht weiß, was sie hier alles angepasst haben
Also die Partikeleffekte und Lichteffekte sind schon mal besser als 1997
Was passiert eigentlich? Ich glaub, das hab ich nie ausprobiert
Oh, okay, war damit zu rechnen
Ich vermute schon, dass sich an der Story nicht viel geändert hat, ja
Also der Mod sagt selbst, dass sie versucht, die Partikelleffekte zu reduzieren
Und ich muss auch sagen
Auf der einen Seite zum Besseren, auf der anderen Seite aber auch nicht
Weil ich finde, Xen ist in Black Mesa viel zu lang
Vor allem die zweite Hälfte von Xen ist viel zu lang gestreckt
Okay, Explosionen sehen auch besser aus als 1997
Ja, viel besser
Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum ich Xen in Black Mesa nicht so lieb
Weil ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum ich Xen in Black Mesa nicht so lieb
Okay, Explosionen sehen auch besser aus als 1997
Ja, viel besser
Okay
Wait a minute
Das ist da wo ich runter gehüpft bin oder?
Ich glaube ich bin einfach nur zu pepega gewesen
Das zu checken
Okay
What the f...
Hab ich das irgendwie kaputt gemacht gerade?
Das ist das nicht...
Ist das...
Broken?
Och nee oder?
Highly trained professional
Der Fahrstuhl ist gerade durch den
geschlossenen Schacht gefahren
Ja ich glaube ich hab es irgendwie kaputt gemacht
Kann ich vielleicht jetzt hier runter?
Ah da ist der Fahrstuhl
Okay
Ich glaube ich hab es irgendwie
kaputt gemacht
Fuck
Okay
Rekt
XD
Aber Leitern klettern kann er nicht
Rein da
Jetzt
Ich erinnere mich
Okay
Bullsquid oder?
Bullsquid?
Half life? Ich glaube schon
Oh
Okay
Okay danke für den Zapf
Jetzt wirds gegrillt
In your face
Jawohl
Rakete
Bam
Get schreckt
Das Sounddesign war schon richtig klasse bei Half-Life
Nice
Richtig nice
Oh shit
Ich hab keine Pistolen Muni mehr
Und nix
Sehr unpraktisch nur mit der Shotgun
Aber ich krieg glaube ich gleich den Revolver
Und beim Revolver müssen wir ausbilden
Der Revolver hat angeblich noch
Leben
Ihr Leben zu verlieren
Guck mal hier
Liegen Überreste vorn rum
Ich glaub jetzt gibt es gleich den Revolver
Da hab ich noch ein bisschen Muni
Und das Bein gebrochen
Ja das juckt ihn doch nicht
Wow
Blub blub blub
Hoffentlich keine Headcrabs
Doch es gibt Waffeninspections
Hat man doch gerade gesehen
Aber wie kann man
Schade dass man die anscheinend nicht von Hand
Aufrufen kann
Was hat
Wir schwimmen hier erstmal raus
Dann gucken wir uns den Revolver an
Was die dem für neue Fähigkeiten
Gegeben haben
Hier schonmal nicht
Da
Okay also was kann der Revolver
Neues
Rechte Maustaste
Macht nix, mittlere Maustaste
Sniper Mode
Ah
I see
No Scope
360 Time
One on one of rust
Jetzt kann es eigentlich nix mehr passieren
Nein
Ja er sieht besser
Au ich muss aufpassen ich hab kaum noch Leben
Das ist die Original Kampagne gemoddet
Und ich finds bis jetzt auch
Ehrlich gesagt
Besser fürs Jahr 2023 geeignet
Als das reine Original Half-Life
Es sieht ein bisschen besser aus
Also sie haben beispielsweise die Feuereffekte
Ich würde auch sagen ein bisschen die Partikeleffekte
Und teilweise die Beleuchtung verbessert
Und äh
Nein zur Seite
Und die Waffen ein bisschen verbessert
Vor allem vorne weg
Die
Waffen sind jetzt fast alle Projektil
Projektilbasiert
Du bist über nem Gegner
Hast abgedrückt und hast instant getroffen
Wenn du jetzt hier mal guckst
Wie du siehst das sind Projektile die fliegen
Was ich eine sehr gute Idee finde
Was auch Movement
Tatsächlich sinnvoll macht
In Half-Life 1 musstest du normalerweise
Überhaupt nicht moven
Ähm
Ach hier gehts
Close
Hop
Ähm
Äh
Ah das war so ein Verbindungsstück
So ein Verbindungsstück zwischen den Tunnels
Ja
I get it
Aber Michael
50 Milliarden ich kanns dir echt empfehlen
Das ist ein Game was jeder gespielt haben sollte
Meiner Meinung nach
Wow
Ach
Chat wie seht ihr das
Au
Warum hab ich jetzt so viel Leben verloren
Es ist überhaupt nichts passiert
Solltest du erst das Original spielen
Oder direkt die Mod
Also
Normalerweise würde ich sagen erst das Original
Einfach das was man gesehen hat
Aber wenn du es nur einmal spielen willst
Dann kannst du es ruhig mit dem Mod spielen
Ich find es eigentlich
Es ist das Original
Mit ein paar Quality of Life Sachen
Ein bisschen Optik verbessert
Beispielsweise im Original
Konntest du mit der Brechstange
Nur so machen
So
Und hier hast du einen Sekundär Schlagmodus
Und sogar noch einen Charge Modus
Was ich schon
Wirklich sinnvolle Neuerung finde
Gerade zum Kisten zerstören
Und noch mehr
Und bei der Pistole kannst du einen Silencer drauf machen
Es ist ziemlich alles im Geist des Originals gemacht
Also du könntest schon den Mod spielen
Mod ist übrigens kostenlos
Auf Steam
Half-Life 2 Original oder Mod
Muss ich dir ehrlich sagen
Weiß ich nicht
Ich hab lange kein Half-Life 2 mehr gespielt
Ich würd sagen Leute
Was haltet ihr davon
Wollen wir demnächst nochmal ein richtig krass gemoddetes Half-Life 2 spielen
Ich hab lange kein Half-Life 2 mehr gespielt
Bestimmt 6-7 Jahre
Hab ich Half-Life 2 nicht mehr gespielt
So
Es gibt einen Trick
Ich zeig euch den mal
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich den jetzt hinbekomme
Es gibt einen Trick
Fast
Ihr habt es gesehen
Es geht ohne Tripmines
Wirklich
Wie geht es ohne Tripmines
Ohne Tripmines
Also ich kenn nur das
Ich kenn nicht gut was Half-Life Glitches angeht
Also man kann
Jetzt bin ich stuck
I'm stuck
Also man kann das Level skippen
Ich will euch das nur einmal zeigen
Also man kann das Level irgendwie skippen
Ich glaube man braucht einfach gutes Timing
Ich glaube man braucht einfach
Ich bin wieder stuck
Aber ihr könnt euch ungefähr vorstellen
Wie es funktioniert
Wenn man jemand ist der es kann
Ich bin schon wieder gestuckt
Meint ihr das ist patched
Ne ne ne das ist nicht patched
Das geht bestimmt immer noch
Ich glaube nicht das es patched ist
Okay wir spielen das Level nochmal
Aber theoretisch kann man das skippen
Mach die Minen doch schräg dran
Wow
Hätte ich euch mal beide da durchlaufen lassen
Anstatt Zvoni zu verschwenden
Nicht genau vor dich
Ja siehst du ich hab die Half
Ich hab die Half-Life Glitches einfach nicht drauf
Wir können es nachher nochmal probieren
Moin
Ist sie weg
Also das ist jetzt noch ein cooles Level
Und danach kommt glaube ich das meist gehasste
Half-Life Level
Nämlich das wo man Bahn fährt
Was wahrscheinlich am Bahnfahren liegt
Berechtigterweise
Okay
Jetzt direkt
Ey
Äh
Ich bin verwirrt wo geht es weiter
Also hier schon mal nett
Hier komm ich her
Hier komm ich rein
Ah hier unten
Quickscope
Okay
Bahnlabyrinth wie in echt
Oh ich hab endlich Granaten
Für meine MP5
So muss das
Wird eigentlich Granaten
Okay
Die outplayen wir erstmal
Okay das war blöd ich dachte da kommt jetzt irgendwas
Jetzt aber
Kackviech
Sinnlose Munitionsverschwendung
Okay
Warum mach ich die Tür zu
Muss doch nachher wieder zurück
Hallo
Was ist da los
Ah
Ey
Ich glaub das war totale Munitionsverschwendung
Oder
Das Viech wär da nie raus gekommen
Yep
Klock
Oh
Wieder was nicht down
Das war
Einfach voll in den Kopf geschossen mit der Magnum
Juckt ihr nicht ist eben egal
Interessiert ihr nicht
Guter Helm
Ich hab 6 Granaten die sollte ich vielleicht mal benutzen
Das ist das beste gegen die Soldaten
Bam
Die erste Granate war schonmal komplett für
Für ne Arsch
Das ist auch was was in dem Mod neu ist
Man muss Tapfire machen
Halbes Battlefield hier
Tut mir leid
Oh jawoll
Leckt
Hast du irgendwas vergessen
Ey
Mein Gott was halten die aus
Mit der Shotgun davorstehen
Und ins Gesicht ballern
Ja easy kann man mal 5 Schuss aushalten
Vielmehr kann hier nicht mehr sein
Jawoll
Wie sich der zerlegt hat
Ich hoffe das war es jetzt
Gucken wir nochmal schnell
Ob jetzt alles down ist
Die Explosivkisten lassen wir
Weil wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe
Dann kommen hier gleich noch ein paar Viecher
Aus der anderen Richtung
Wenn man fertig ist
X
Ja
So
Jugendfreier Inhalt
Nice
So jetzt sind wir auf der Seite
Wo ging es jetzt lang
Ah man muss den Fahrstuhl runterfahren
Ja ja ich erinnere mich
Fahrstuhl fahren
Outplayed
Outmoved
Ähm
Ich bilde mir auch ein
Man soll hier eigentlich gar nicht lang
Sondern man kommt eigentlich von der anderen Seite
Ich glaube man kommt eigentlich von der anderen Seite
Wenn man den offiziellen Weg geht
Stimmt ne
War mir nämlich auch so
Dass das irgendwie ein bisschen verkehrt ist
Wo ich hier gerade rumstelze
Ne
Aber bei Black Mesa
Kommt man von der anderen Seite
Dann war es so
Bei Black Mesa kommt man von der anderen Seite
Ne man
Okay okay doch doch
Bei Black Mesa kommt man auf jeden Fall
Von der anderen Seite
Das haben sie ein bisschen geändert
Ähm
Bin mir gar nicht sicher
Ich glaube hier unten musste man hin um den Motor zu entstacken
Ey
Alter wie viel hältst du aus
Oh oh oh oh
Puh
Viel zu viel unsinnig
Damage genommen aber ja
Entstacken
Und jetzt
Einschalten
Die Gegner sind wie Oblivion Level
Ne oder
Also wenn überhaupt ist das neu in dem Mod
Das glaube ich nicht
Das ist die Bait
Ey wir haben es geschafft
Wow
So jetzt müssen wir uns noch
Mit den restlichen Marines auseinandersetzen
Die wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe
Jetzt gleich den Fahrstuhl runter gefahren kommen
Und in ihre eigene Falle laufen
Pass mal auf
Da sind sie schon
She baited
Aber ich bilde mir ein
Da sind immer noch welche oben
Ja
Achtung
Okay
Warum halten die dudes so viel aus
Hä guck mal habt ihr es gerade gesehen
Der eine hat zwei Doppel Shotgun Shots
Ausgehalten
Oh
Hat es den schon zerlegt
Nice
Eine andere nur ein
Warum sind die Marines
Gegen dich du bist doch eigentlich ein normaler Mensch
Ja das
Dazu müsste man die Half-Life Story erklären
Also das ist folgendermaßen
Ist nicht so dass es super kompliziert wäre oder so
Also
Man ist Wissenschaftler in einer geheimen
Die Shotgun ist der RNG
Ja habe ich gemerkt
Man ist Wissenschaftler in so einer geheimen Forschungsstation
Und
Man führt da Experimente durch
Und die Experimente gehen schief
Und jetzt hat man Aliens quasi so in die eigene Welt geholt
Und das Militär ist unterwegs
Und versucht alle die das gesehen haben
Zu beseitigen
Dass es halt nicht rauskommt
Dass man da geheime
Geheime Experimente
Durchgeführt hat
Die Half-Life Story
Ey
Also eins muss man sagen
Der Mod übertreibt es mit Headcrabs
So ich glaube jetzt kann ich hier einschalten
Ich habe sehr wenig Leben
Hi
Äh
Äh was muss ich
Nochmal machen
Ich glaube raus
Und irgendwas einschalten
Ne
Ey hold on
Äh ich muss erst wieder hoch
Und jetzt hier raus
Genau
Okay das Fisch muss ich erstmal ablenken
Falls ich es ablenken lässt
Oh
Was ist das
Kannst du dich mal verpissen vielleicht
Ist das möglich ja
Achtung
Debated
Vielleicht soll ich einfach aus dem Fenster
Vielleicht soll ich einfach aus dem Fenster springen
Oh blöde Idee
Oh shit
Ich glaube ich sollte
Besser gar nicht hier rein rennen
Okay erstmal hier rein
Und jetzt
Ja komm her
Hier
Fuck
Ich hab mehr Leben
Ich muss nur den Schalter drücken
Schalter drücken
Okay
Wait a minute
Wo ist das Vieh hin
Warum kommt das Vieh
Habe ich das outmoved gerade vielleicht
Oh es klitscht
Hier bin ich
Ja ja hier
Oh
Okay auf
Komm her
Kackvieh
Dead
Ah ausschalten geht nicht mehr
Okay
Ausschalten ist overrated, outdated, debated
Der musste schon ausschalten
Kann ich noch in die Kiste
Vielleicht gucken
Handgranate
Nice
Au
Ah ja ich hab den Strom
Eingeschaltet
Nicht so high IQ gewesen von mir
Gab es medikits
Wait a minute
Didi dankeschön für den Zaun
Wo gab es medikits
Wo denn
Hab ich nicht gesehen
Hier
Ach da
Ah nice
Ne die hab ich tatsächlich
Nicht gesehen
So jetzt kommt das wohl meist
Gehasste Level in ganz Half-Life
So
Jetzt fahren wir nämlich eine Runde mit der Bahn
MonkaDB
MonkaSteer
Ja guck hier wo wir drüber springen wollten
Bam kann man jetzt einfach durchfahren mit der Bahn
Ich nicht
Ich brauch ein bisschen Munition
Ich mein
Ich hab zu wenig Muni
Gerade was Pistolen
Wobei hab ich gar nicht
Eigentlich hab ich mittlerweile genug
Oh
Ich glaube wir müssen das gar nicht
Äh
Ich fahr einfach mal durch
Ok
Gib Gas
Jawohl
Oh
Gerade noch überlebt
So jetzt kann man irgendwie tricks
Ich kenn mich hier leider in dem Level nicht so gut aus
Also wenn man Ahnung von hat ist man hier easy schnell durchgerannt
Ohne mit der Bahn zu fahren
Man kann
Man kann die Hälfte vom Level skippen
Wenn man nicht mit der Bahn fährt
Niemand
Niemand mag dieses Level so wirklich
Gehts hier lang
Ah Absteckgleis
Einfach nichts
Doch Magnum Muni
Ich
Ah 3 3 Schuss noch
Das ist glücklicherweise auch nicht so lang
Wenn man weiß wo es lang ist
Woah
Close
Sonst wär ich dead kill gewesen
Jetzt können wir mal was ausprobieren
Sniper Mode
Mal auf
Bam
Rekt
Oh
Wow
Kann man das kaputt machen
Oh
Ist glaube ich kaputt
So
So jetzt kann man das umstellen
Aber jetzt
Man muss irgendwie da hoch
Um das umzustellen
Äh ne das will ich jetzt ja gar nicht
Man muss irgendwie da hoch
Damit man
Diesen Kran bewegen kann
So wie kommt man da hin
Oh man ich
Ich mag das Level nicht
Ist nicht dead
Blind ge
Mit Mine hoch klitschen
Ach ne
Moment hier waren wir schon oder
Wait a minute
Wir fahren gerade im Kreis
Oh shit
Ich noob wusste eigentlich das es kommt
Wir fahren im Kreis
Oh
Okay jetzt geht es hier lang
Ich bräuchte ein bisschen Leben
Achtung der wird wieder weg gesniped
Leben perfekt
Ähm
Ist hier unten irgendwie noch was drin
Ah
Sehr schön
Und ein bisschen Munition
Oh
Gone
Langsam
Ähm
Okay
Ei
Gut das ich das Teil habe
Das macht ordentlich Damage
Ein bisschen zu spät
Tschü tschü tschü tschü
Noch mehr Grenades
Ach wir sind jetzt oben
Im Häuschen
Kran weg
Nice
Wie ich hier keinen Überblick habe
Ja komm spring mal an mir vorbei
Nice nice headcrab
Habt ihr in Half-Life auch immer so das Verlangen jede Kiste zu...
Ja hab ich
Hab ich
So jetzt müssen wir hier einmal
Nein ey
Alter ich komm jetzt gebaded vor
Warum bin ich schon zweimal
In das Elektro-Kabel reingefallen
Jetzt müssen wir hier rum
Äh jetzt
Äh jetzt kommt das mit dem
Mit dem Türmen
Dachte ich eigentlich
Sack
Sackshot
Ey
Ja
Ich fahr bestimmt nicht in der Mitte damit hoch
Äh was hab ich denn jetzt gerade getroffen
Hä was zum
Der Typ ist
Der Typ ist tödlich hier
Guck mal
Okay
Das erscheint mir ein kleiner Bug zu sein
Äh das wars
Highly trained professional
Ja